alors jean d'ormesson quand je vais
inviter dans bad minuit vous m'avez dit
pourquoi m'inviter vous oui vous dire
pourquoi parce que vous respirez la
gaieté jésus qui pétillent quel choc la
seule chose que je pourrais vous
reprocher ses dettes vous êtes parent
avec peletier de saint-fargeau quand
même qui est un v6 de haoues était très
fier je le redis rien à part en mission
et m'a demandé ce que ses parents
d'avoir quelqu'un qui a reculé en 2016
qu'il y aurait assassiné quelques jours
après il a été assassiné au palais royal
à peu près là où elles resteront véfour
maintenant dans un restaurant qui
s'appelait février jean marc veya
il ya eu là une belle chance il est
tombé sur la garde du roy
il s'appelait paris nice et le barde du
roi évidemment elle avait rencontré
plusieurs fois à versailles puisque il
est fait de l'entourage de louis saez et
malgré ça puisqu'il était
conventionnelle et qu'il était aussi un
ami leur vestiaire était l'amant
non je pense à la vente et la mort du
roi
bon moi je ne pense pas que j'aurais
voté la mort du roi sur peut pas voter
la mort de la reine les vingt années du
règne de louis saint jean est et
l'apogée de la france
écoutez je ne sais pas si vous
connaissez pas ce que disait mon frère
kpatcha à l'académie bach se disait
supposons que louis saez soit mort en
1880 4784 1785 ou si ce n'est bien la
révolution aurait eu lieu tout de même
et tous les historiens direct quel
malheur qu'il soit mort s'il y avait
vécu il ya la révolution leurs épaules
du lieu où elle se serait bien passé
alors vous voyez je pense qu'il est tout
à fait vrai d'où le temps se fasse des
rois libéral pour tout à fait c'est sous
son règne que des droits de l'homme ont
été proclamés vous ne pensez pas vous
faites partie d'une espèce en voie de
disparition il ya des gens qui
travaillent beaucoup mais qui donne
toujours comme ça à l'impression d'une
certaine facilité
2 toujours à l'aise je vous ai vus
arriver tout à l'heure vous êtes à
l'aise vous entretenez avec tout le
monde
vous êtes star dans les dîners en ville
parce que j'aime brillant et cultivé
je pensais pas que des gens que vous il
y en a de moins en moins d'abord j'aime
bien je travaille beaucoup je suis sûr
vous travaillé et j'ai longtemps fait
croire que je ne travaillais pas besoin
maintenant c'est presque difficile de
faire croire que je ne travaille pas
beaucoup parce qu'on ne voit plus
beaucoup dans les dîners en ville une
hilary cocktail parce que je travaille
et le week-end le samedi ou dimanche
évidemment je travaille je suis pas si
les résultats sont à la hauteur du
travail mais en tout cas je travaille
il fera un petit reproche dire que louis
pauwels il faisait moins bien que vous
mais ces articles sont pas mal écrit
comment ils sont soit très très très
bien sorti avec les miens sont pas bien
et que je trouve que c'est un peu moins
bien que le livre vous donner autant de
mal que lui pour faire vos papiers du
figaro magazine
je ne sais pas en tout cas c'est vrai
que j'ai fait mieux
ouais mais c'est vrai que j'attache plus
important support solide
suite aux articles parus en parler vie
moi chaque semaine je fais une page de
livre dans le figaro magazine et c'est
vrai alors que bourbon semble un peu
plus les accords un peu plus la terre
doit faire un effort
ouais je me permets tu nous avais raison
tâche ardue alors cette super brillant
minul n'en disconvient mais on se
demande finalement sur glace votre
brillance des convictions profondes
passant de cette catholique du caté
ligne
le papa temps de l'année la barre peg
vous le savez le tapis est ce que vous
faites entre la situation de l'afrique
du sud je suis tout à fait contre
l'apartheid
qu'est ce que vous faites contre la
porte alors je vous dis à des beurres
j'ai joué aussi bien que ça commençait à
peu trop bien joli ça va vous avez s'est
passé avant alors je dois vous dire que
quand j'ai été nommé directeur du figaro
est une ou des alcools et yahoo
raymond aron affame discours en trois
points oui a dit d'abord pardonnez moi
il ya eu d'abord il est très intelligent
voter pour lui
deuxièmement il est d'une ignorance
ensuite le bébé n'a pas ça on y sent
toujours voté pour lui
et troisièmement et c'est ce que je suis
il a des convictions très ferme mais
extrêmement vague c'est très commode
doit évoluer
alors c'est vrai que je suis pas une je
ne suis pas un militant
je suis un militant pour certaines
causes que je crois je bois et d'animer
les justes par exemple pour la majorité
actuelle que contre le que contre
l'apartheid et fort vous pouvez pas
venir si on fait des papiers les
abonnements j'ai d'abord
jenny lee avec l'unesco un endroit les
nations unies qui ont condamné le plus
fermement l'apartheid
donc je ne suis pas suspect de défendre
l'apartheid ensuite je crois qu'il ya un
peu d'hypocrisie dans le sas et à
l'apartheid si on veut rompre avec les
régimes dont on ne partage pas les
opinions et je ne partage pas l'opinion
régnant en afrique du sud
je ne partage pas non plus celle ci
règne en russie
et si on rompt avec la tête du sud ce
que je comprends très bien qu'on demande
pour l'instant pour contre avec six
grands et pourront qui nous a fait plus
de mal que c'est le peuple attendait qu
on en fait je me suis prononcé très long
et très violent entre puis recherche de
supports pour pinochet
je ne suis pas pour l'afrique du sud je
ne suis pas pour le régime soviétique et
gars que je vis avec eux
et je trouve que ce qui s'est passé ces
jours ci c'est à dire le refus des
polonais du référendum jardin ce qui est
quelque chose supéfiants car j'ai
investi leur ai dit est ce que vous
approuvez les réformes démocratiques
est-ce que vous approuvez que je vous
donne un peu plus de liberté et les
polonais ont répondu non c'est un peu
pareil sur le racisme ne pas pas de
condamner le racing
qu'est ce qui nous fait contre loos tout
à fait contre le racisme vous faites
quoi
je fais quoi ce que chateaubriand lui il
avait la duchesse de berry se désole du
mal sans délai à prague je vais vous
dire ce que je me plais dans le figaro
magazine où vous approuvez beaucoup mon
ami pour elle ce que la défense possible
beaucoup et bien je suis un des rares à
m élevé avec autant de force contre le
pen ben si vous trouvez que c'est parce
qu'elle prive fournissent au lieu de
s'élever contre le pen dans le figaro
magazine
et bien maintenant tout le monde le fait
mais j'ai même reçu pas mal de lettres
des lecteurs trouvant que je t'ai dans
le figaro magazine
pierre ébauche vous tomberiez amoureuse
une petite bird une beurette moi oui si
elle si elle me plaisait oui ils sont
localisés joie problème dans l'ombre le
problème je crois aussi que j'ai écrit
et que j'écris que si ma fille tombée
amoureuse d'un noir et ben je fais tout
à faire chanter qu'elle n'épouse à
condition naturellement qu'ils tiennent
président de la république jeudi soir
frank sinatra bien parce q pourquoi
exposer des nullards une troupe
villarreal et blanc aussi c'est minable
alors
il faut prendre ce qu'il ya de mieux
partout et naturellement l'ombre la
différence entre un blanc jaune et un
loi j'ai quand même une différence entre
un jour les uns blanche pour que les
joueurs soient plus intelligents
pardonnez moi d'être à 6 mais je crains
tu le jaune soit plus intelligente les
blancs vous avez écrit quelque chose moi
qui m'a beaucoup touché parce que je
pense un peu la même chose ça lui si un
jour je me retrouve en prison ce sera
génial parce que moi je pourrais écrire
des livres
oui à condition naturellement pour
montre est bien on va en voir qu'on
m'envoie comment vous l'appelez une
beurette voilà un petit buzz comme on en
voit une beurette et qu'on traite bien
j'ai un bon lit que j'ai trois manches
et que mais elle avait six mois j'aurais
été enchantés visant à la bastille où
chercher d'oeuvre